[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program with the David Horowitz freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy the British supermarket chain
Tesco is getting heat for a Christmas ad
featuring hid jabbed muesli m'as and the
so called Muslim reformer Maajid Nawaz
is enraged not at Tesco but at those who
are complaining about their ad the
British Network LBC says the supermarket
has responded to an outpouring of racist
abuse after featuring a Muslim family in
a Christmas advert and Nawaz adds your
real agenda here speaking to the critics
is you just want a white nativist non
Muslim Britain
once again Islam is not a race there are
Muslims of all races objecting to
Muslims being featured in a Christmas ad
is not racism it stems from Tesco's
obvious agenda in putting Muslims in the
ad in the first place to remind non
Muslims in Britain that Muslims are
there they're there to stay and only
racist bigoted Islamophobes would have
any objection it's propaganda and
manipulation disguised as an ad for
Turkey Nawaz meanwhile blasts those who
were unhappy about the ad he says the
only conclusion I can come to is that
this is driven and fuelled by rising
anti-muslim sentiment that wants no
Muslim presence in this country and will
take any opportunity to decry inba moan
a semblance of a Muslim presence in this
country your real agenda here is that
you just want a white nativists non
Muslim Britain you want to hark back to
that nostalgic sense you have of a
country before immigration that's the
only conclusion I can come to because
you're not happy either way if Muslims
refuse to integrate you complain if
Muslims integrate you complain that
tells me that there's an axe to grind
and you're grinding it really Nawaz
that's the only conclusion you can come
to what a failure of imagination
here's another conclusion you can come
to non-muslims in Britain are concerned
about jihad terror and the repeated
boasts from Islamic jihadists that
Britain will before too long become a
Sharia State
they don't see anyone in the British
government or establishment media
addressing those concerns adequately no
one is challenging Muslims to work for
reform no one's questioning what is
being taught in mosques no one is
opposing the establishment of Sharia
enclaves instead tens of thousands of
British girls have been sacrificed to
Muslim rape gangs operating in a chord
with Quranic teaching because British
officials were too afraid of being
called racist and Islamophobia to
prosecute them jihad preachers speak
freely at mosques all over the country
often coming from other countries and
having no trouble getting into Britain
because barring them would be
Islamophobic and while all this is going
on you tell us the Tesco featuring
Muslims and a Christmas ad is a sign of
integration and that we're racist for
opposing it in reality every Muslim in
Britain could celebrate Christmas and it
would not be in the slightest degree a
sign of integration why not because it's
not on the point when Muslims sincerely
renounce and work against jihad terror
and all the aspects of Sharia that
conflict with British law the denial of
the freedom of speech the denial of the
freedom of conscience the
institutionalized discrimination against
women and non-muslims the death penalty
for gays the stoning for adultery the
amputation of the hand for theft and all
the rest then they're integrating
celebrating Christmas not integrating
why not because even though the
celebration of Christmas is often
denounced by Muslim clerics it does not
touch upon the aspects of Islam that
make non-muslims concern and is not
necessarily an indication that Muslims
have renounced those aspects of Islam
there are unfortunately numerous
examples of Muslims who lived in close
proximity to non-muslims and were quite
friendly to them until it came time for
jihad the June 19 2013 edition of the
New York Times carried a photo with the
caption empty Somme Ali Abood with her
son Jafar says to her husband
a Syrian Alawite was killed by his Sunni
friend this illustrates how the call to
jihad can override all existing
loyalties
such that a Syrian Alawite can suddenly
be murdered by his Sunni friend there
are innumerable other examples Boston
Marathon jihadi Tamerlan tsarnaev's
September 11th 2011 throat-slitting
murder of his Jewish best friend is a
prominent example an anecdote from the
Ottoman Empire in the late 19th century
illustrates the same point a Muslim
woman recounted then one night my
husband came home and told me that the
padishah had sent word that we were to
kill all the Christians in our village
and that we would have to kill our
neighbors I was very angry and told him
that I did not care who gave such orders
they were wrong these neighbors had
always been kind to us and if he dared
to kill them Allah would pay us out
I tried all I could to stop him but he
killed them kill them with his own hand
so yeah Majid you can call me racist all
you want but I don't find it a wonderful
reassurance that tesco shows us Muslims
celebrating Christmas I want to see
Muslims renounce Jihad terror what are
you doing to facilitate that I am Robert
Spencer
[Music]